so what is a screenplayer what might it
be a screenplay is an exploration it's
about the thing you don't know to step
into the abyss it's necessary
necessarily start somewhere anywhere
there is a starting point but the rest
is undetermined it is a secret
even from you
there's no template for a screenplay or
there shouldn't be there are at least as
many screenplay possibilities as there
are people who write them here's what I
know about a screenplay
simply that is a text that describes
what happens in a movie and I'm not even
sure about this definition I think what
might make this form of endeavor
exciting for writers
is that they find themselves in an
environment where they are encouraged to
use their powers to explore the world
their minds and the form itself so I
think the danger of craft is that it
needs to be in second position
to what it is that you're doing I think
you need to be willing to be naked
when you do anything creatively in film
or in any other form that's really what
you have to do